there will be again no payday today for
some 800,000 federal employees due to
the partial government shutdown two
bills that would end the standoff both
got a majority in the Senate yesterday
but not the 60 votes needed to pass the
Democrats plan with no money for a
border wall got the most support
including six Republican votes Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where there is
new optimism that a deal can be made to
end the 35 days shutdown Nancy a long
time since we've heard the word optimism
in this conversation good morning to you
good morning I'd call it tempered
optimism because there is this new
bipartisan push to reopen the government
short-term to allow workers to get paid
to allow these border negotiations to
continue without hurting the economy but
the president says while he's open to it
he'd like to get that downpayment on the
wall first Democrats called that
unreasonable I wouldn't be happy with it
I wouldn't be happy but we have a lot of
alternatives President Trump threw cold
water on a rare bipartisan proposal that
emerged after two competing bills to end
the shutdown failed the motion is not
agreed to
Democrats and Republicans want to fund
the government for three weeks to create
a window for border talks for the first
time in 34 days you've had a bipartisan
group of senators coming together our
goal is again to push these negotiations
forward the proposal would allow federal
workers to get much-needed back pay the
Commerce Secretary and billionaire
Wilbur Ross said he couldn't understand
why some of the 800,000 workers are
strapped for cash
there's no real reason why they
shouldn't be able to get a loan against
it that didn't go over well on Capitol
Hill and this is to let them eat cake
kind of attitude or at this DC pop-up
food bank you need to leave your office
and go talk to regular people before
making stupid statements like that
in 2013 the New York Times found that
nearly two-thirds of federal workers
don't have enough in their savings to
pay their expenses for two weeks
how ludicrous it is that this government
is shut down over a promise the praise
of the United States couldn't keep the
president's allies say it's Democrats
who are prolonging the pain we're in a
shutdown today because they are now
unwilling to fund 234 miles a border
wall less than they voted for in 2013
everyone claims they want this to end
but the President and Democratic leaders
haven't even met for 16 days I mean how
do you work this out if you don't sit
down and talk it through well we have
met
we've met every time the last time we
met it was a photo op for the President
to leave the room the president said
yesterday that furloughed workers should
be able to get a break from their
grocery stores leading even some members
of his own party to question whether he
understands how stores work the TSA did
announce this morning that it is
repurposing some funds and will be able
to provide one week of back pay for
security agents who worked over the
holidays Norah
all right Nancy thank you and good
question